I'm just gonna head something off at the
pass right here the person we're
covering in today's video has a
Mongolian name it's an old Mongolian
name we're not really even sure how it
would be pronounced and I'm certainly
not Mongolian so I'm just gonna go with
coulda you know I looked up some videos
on YouTube that seems to be a sort of
accepted Western pronunciation it's what
I'm going with if you really want to you
can have a go at me in the comments so
the Mongolian Empire is rooms for their
barbaric conquests and the power of
their great leaders that managed to
spread the Empire across several
continents but one of the most
fascinating people who has been
forgotten from the Empire is the warrior
princess cutter Yoon Shi was the
great-great granddaughter of Genghis
Khan and she truly inherited his
strength in battle unlike many other
princesses and queens throughout the
history of the world
Kuta yin was remembered for her own
glory rather than the achievements of a
husband or a son she may just have been
the strongest Mongolian warrior of all
time and in this week's by graphics her
life before we get into the details
about the life of cooter Yoon it's
important to go over some of the details
of the Mongolian Empire for thousands of
years various tribes in Mongolia went to
war with one another and they were never
united under one single government lands
and horses were taken as spoils of war
women and children were seen as the
property of men and they were used as
trophies of conquest powerful men had
more than one wife and chieftains
typically had a harem genghis khan
became the first leader to unite all of
mongolia he achieved this by training
his army to be masterful warriors that
were stronger than many other army in
the world they trained falcons to send
messages and communicate with one
another which helped him to spread his
army over vast territories he pushed his
men to train harder to become a new
breed of super warrior Genghis Khan once
said a man's greatest pleasure is to
defeat his enemies to drive them before
him to take from them that which they
possessed to see those whom they
cherished in tears to ride their horses
and to hold their way
and daughters in his arms Genghis Khan's
army was so strong they were able to
defeat the tribes one by one after
uniting Mongolia he set his sights much
farther than his own country he wanted
to become the ruler of the entire world
he took over parts of Asia the Middle
East and Europe it became the largest
empire in the history of humanity even
though their army was known for being
ruthless warriors the Mongolian Empire
actually brought a lot of innovation to
the world during times of peace they
were tolerant of religions they
encouraged international trade and they
were known for their diplomacy Genghis
Khan had several wives of his own and he
had many many children
his grandson Kublai Khan became the
ruler of Mongolia in the year 1260 and
his brothers and cousins held positions
of power all over the Empire
unfortunately if the Cabaye Khan he was
not as feared as his great-grandfather
had once been a Mongolia would
eventually begin to break off into civil
wars comply Khan would even go to war
with his own brother Erik Polk a man
named Kaidu was Cabaye khan's cousin and
he was the leader of the House of Saud I
the two cousins disagreed with one
another on how to run the Empire and
this would eventually cause them to go
to war as well Qaeda had 14 sons but his
favorite child by far was his daughter
cootie Yuna
an Italian Explorer called Marco Polo
wrote down the history of the Mongolian
Empire whilst living amongst Kublai
Khan's raw court most of what is known
about koreans life came from his books
as well as some comments made by persian
statesman named rationale dinner she was
called by several names including idea
which translates to shining moon well
this is a beautiful name to give to a
baby girl she would grab to prove that
she was far from a dainty princess
[Laughter]
because of Genghis Khan's legacy future
generations of Mongolian Warriors were
trained to be some of these strongest
people on the planet if they wanted the
Mongolian Empire to stretch across the
globe they needed to be prepared to take
down any enemy by the age of two boys
were already learning how to shoot bows
and arrows and ride on horseback they
wrestled one another to learn and hand
combat they practiced both the Chinese
martial arts of Kung Fu as well as
ancient Mongolian fighting techniques
they weren't just doing all of this
training on foot either all of their
fighting techniques also needed to be
executed while riding at high speeds on
horseback
this included both wrestling and archery
because of this and their enemies would
almost never be able to knock a
Mongolian of this horse no matter how
hard they tried in Mongolia horses are a
huge part of their culture the number of
horses actually outnumbers the human
population people late horse Mason's
they drank mares milk this milk was
actually fermented into an alcoholic
beverage which is considered to be the
national drink of Mongolia to this very
day there is a saying a Mongol without a
horse is like a bird without the wings
while all of this training fighting and
partying was normal for boys it was
always never taught to girls women were
expected to be delicate and subservient
to men while they took care of the
farming the child-rearing and various
household tasks cutie Yoon was a tomboy
since she was young and she wanted to
practice fighting with the boys far more
than she was willing to dance or play
with dolls in his record of his
adventures Marco Polo describes Korean
as looking statuesque she was so tall
one might mistake her for a giant s
since the members of the royal family
always chose the most beautiful women in
the country to take as their wives she
would have falsely been very pretty most
likely looking like a modern-day
supermodel but unlike most princesses
cuter youn isn't rumored for her looks
she was known for her incredible
wrestling skills you could say that she
was the world's first celebrity female
wrestler long before the ages of glow in
the WWE
she was so ahead of her time it would
take hundreds of years after her death
before female wrestling would even be an
acceptable sport around the world
Mongolian star wrestling is very
different from what you see on TV or
even what you saw in your high school
there was no separation of weight class
just two people lock arms and they try
to push each other over
anyway they can imagine armwrestling
only using your entire body to push the
other person down to the ground once the
opponent is knocked to the floor the
person who remains standing is the
winner because of this the person's
physical strength usually determines who
the victor will be Korean practiced
wrestling and continue to get stronger
every day
she was seen better than any man she had
ever gone up against and she had the
goal of becoming the strongest wrestler
in the world when she was old enough to
get married several suitors began to
show interest in making her their wife
her father King kaiju began to prepare
some eligible suitors for her Korean was
not afraid to speak her mind to her
father and rebellious Lee announced that
she could never marry a man unless he
was able to defeat her in a wrestling
match at that time even princes were not
usually able to choose who their wife
would be politics it trumped falling in
love and marriages were usually meant to
keep peaceful ties across the Empire but
since she showed so much strength kaiju
gave his daughter his word that she
would be free to marry any man of her
choosing an official proclamation was
written and spread across the Empire
announcing that his daughter was looking
for her husband as long as he defeated
her in wrestling the entry fee was a
hundred horses if they lost that have to
forfeit their horses to the house of
awliya die which would only increase the
wealth and power of their army despite
the fact that horses are such a huge
part of Mongolian culture people usually
only had one or two per households if
they were lucky owning a hundred horses
was no simple task a man would have had
to come from some kind of nobility to
even collect the entry fee we know
there's at least 100 men showed up at
the house a forged eye to challenge
cooter Yoon to a match because she
connected a fleet of over 10,000 horses
it's safe to assume that many of these
men who came to win the match were
probably feeling overly confidence
before they arrived they probably
thought that defeating a princess would
be a piece of cake but they left feeling
totally humiliated it probably took a
few matches before word spread that this
was no ordinary princess and that men
would need to train before they could
even think about challenging her these
wrestling matches were talked about
through our small gala and many people
like Marco Polo traveled to see fights
ku Thien would show up wearing a garment
called Kendall this was usually worn by
men when they practiced the martial arts
but she would show up wearing a version
that was made with expensive fabrics
suitors usually showed up wearing a
similar style even though they were
fighting they still showed up looking
their best to the crowd in the year 1280
when Kotian was twenty years old the son
of king parma arrives you try as lark in
winning a match against the princess the
prince offered to wager a thousand
horses instead of the typical 100 Marco
Polo described him as being young and
incredibly good-looking and he was
surrounded by an entourage of servants
when he showed up in the town and
announced that he wanted to battle
cootie in for her hand in marriage men
women and children all showed up to
witness this wrestling match and to true
the biggest crowd by far her parents
were very impressed they thought that he
was a perfect match for her and
encouraged cooter Yuna to lose on
purpose so she would marry him she
replied that she would never lose on
purpose for any amount of money the man
who was truly worthy of her hand in
marriage would win without her throwing
the match to his credit this Prince
lasted the longest out of any other
wrestler to ever lock arms with the
princess after she slammed the Prince
onto the palace floor the cheering
stopped ins the room went silent for the
first time ever the audience was
naturally disappointed that she had won
since he lasted the longest in the
wrestling match of any other man maybe
cooter Yoon was truly considering if she
should throw the match however this man
was exactly the sort of husband her
father would have arranged for if you
think about it that does kind of defeat
the purpose of her being able to choose
her husband in the first place
[Music]
offer years of kicking ass and taking
names people began to wonder why could
he Yoon wanted to be a single virgin for
the rest of her life rumors began to
spread about her
in modern times one might assume that
she was a lesbian was asexual or perhaps
even transgender despite long Golia
being one of the most progressive
countries in the world at that time they
were still not accepting of
homosexuality so it's very possible that
cootie Yoon had a strong sense of self
and she wasn't going to allow her father
to force her into a marriage that would
make her miserable at the time the idea
of being a lesbian wasn't even an option
in the minds of the public rumors spread
that k2 may have even had an incestuous
relationship with his daughter however
this is probably unlikely unfortunately
if the rumor that was said of a lot of
women back then it was just so out of
the ordinary that a daughter was held in
such high regard by her father and that
he allowed her to remain unmarried the
situation was so odd people simply
didn't know what to make of it according
to a Persian statesman named rash it out
in cootie Yoon was fighting so hard for
freedom because she was in love with a
man named Gaza
he was the Mongolian leader of the
Persian territories and a direct
descendant of Genghis Khan as well that
meant that there would have been cousins
and maybe their union would have been
forbidden because they were too closely
related whether the theory is true or
not Korean never did marry Gosselin he
is remembered for converting to Islam
and setting the new precedent for future
rulers in modern-day Iran he married
another princess named Coco chin who was
nicknamed the blue princess and
remembered for her stunning beauty Marco
Polo helped escort her across the desert
to meet her new husband cootie UN the
polar opposite of this day-t frail
princess it's possible that a heart
belonged to a man that she simply
couldn't have we never do learn if cute
even got married if she remains
unmarried having an affair with men or
if she was secretly enjoying a harem of
her own most historians believe that she
was single for the rest of her life
because a royal wedding surely would
have been on the record somewhere what
we do know though is that if she got
married she would have never been
allowed to live out her one true passion
in life which was to be a warrior and
she continued to do just that
[Music]
like the male Mongolian warriors of her
day could even participated in many
battles alongside her father and his
army since she was lighter than a male
rider she was able to gallop in on her
horse at faster speeds than a male
counterparts and she was just as strong
Marco Polo describes her technique of
galloping up to an enemy soldier on the
opposite side of the battlefield picking
him up with just one hands and lifting
his body off the ground while on
horseback and delivering the enemy back
to her side of the battle she was like a
hawk flying in on its prey and the enemy
was understandably terrified of her
Kaidu Khan felt that Kuti unit was the
best warrior in his army and she would
have been a very capable leader she was
even given a silver medallion called ger
G to wear around her neck this is like
the modern-day equivalent of becoming a
decorated general she is the only
Mongolian woman to ever hold that honor
and let's just appreciate that statement
for a moment I do to say that his
daughter was the strongest warrior in
his entire army is a big deal even in
modern times it would be almost unheard
of to say that a woman is stronger than
an entire army full of men and the
Mongolians they were born and bred to be
war machines even though Kaidu khan
wanted to appoint cooter unis his
success of putting a woman in charge was
against the rules this was fine with
Goethe you know because she was much
more at home on the battlefields than in
a diplomatic position despite her
hesitation to take over the throne as a
young women she still attended her
father's court and was present for all
of their important meetings so she was
well aware of the local politics the
matter was dropped and all of her
brothers expected that one of them would
be declared the next Khan whenever their
father passed away in the year 1301 King
Kaidu was dying and his dying wish was
for Kuta youn to take over as Khan even
though he had 14 sons none of them could
possibly have been as good of a military
leader and a political leader as his
daughter
he attempted to break all Mongolian
traditions and appoint cootie yoon as
his true heir at this point cootie Yoon
was 41 years old she had years of
experience behind her and she was
respected and feared amongst the army
she was also old enough now to feel that
she was ready to take on the role of
leader however her brothers they weren't
having it a man named duo was given the
position as the new Khan of their
territory in 1306 Kuta Yoon was killed
and there is no record as to exactly how
she died
considering that she had a following of
soldiers who respected her it's possible
that there was a power struggle and that
she was killed most of you may have
never heard of cootie Yoon until now and
that's probably because there is very
little information from people who
actually knew her Marco Polo and
rationale din are the only two
historians who were around in the 1200 s
to write down the details of her life
and each of them only devoted maybe one
or two pages of their books to her story
despite the fact that she was barely
mentioned in these texts of the
Mongolian Empire the story of her
strength was so fascinating it was still
passed along by both Mongolian and
Chinese people by simple word of mouth
just like a childhood game of telephone
her story was convoluted over the years
in the seventeen hundreds a French
writer named Francois patty Delacroix
wrote stories from Asia for a Western
audience and he included a version of
cooter Yoon story only in his telling
she was a Chinese princess named
Turandot who refuses to marry a man
unless he could solve three riddles if
they fail they die the story was
eventually made into an Italian opera QT
u n-- also briefly appeared in the
Netflix series Marco Polo but it barely
scraped the surface of how truly awesome
she actually was and we hope in some way
that with this video we've helped the
true story of cooter Yoon the warrior
princess live on so I really hope you
enjoyed that video if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we got brand new
videos three times a week so hit that
subscribe button and that notification
bell if you actually want to get
notified about these videos and as
always I'll see you next time